one out of four human beings with their
hands on bars shackle in the world are
locked up here in the land of the free
kalief Browder was walking home from a
party when he was stopped by police
then they said we're gonna take you to
the precinct and most likely we're gonna
let you go home and then I never went
home
13th amendment to the Constitution makes
it unconstitutional for someone to be
held as a slave
our exceptions including criminals the
loophole was immediately exploited but
you got after that was a rapid
transition to a mythology of black
criminality beasts that needed to be
controlled you better believe it
monie humor became virtually impossible
for a politician to run and appear soft
on crime the kinds of kids that are
called super predators millions of
dollars will be allocated for prison and
jail facilities three strikes and you
are it was an enormous burden on the
black community but it also violated a
sense of core fairness states were
required to keep these prisons filled
even if nobody was committing a crime so
difficult to talk about mass
incarceration because it has been come
heavily monetized the focus is on taking
people from prison putting them in
Community Corrections parole probation
how much progress is it really is now
there's a private company making money
off the GPS monitor now have more
african-americans under criminal
supervision than all the slaves back in
the 1850s we are the products of the
history that our ancestors chose
products of that set of choices that we
have to understand in order to escape
from
only human after all don't put the blame
on Utz wanted to compete in this year's
competition we finally narrowed it down
to 20 finalists Danny the donkey my
mascot was the first one to have an
anatomically correct